Lex Luthor with
a hair transplant, Elon Musk,
just unveiled his plans
to send human colonists to Mars.
The proposed spaceship
would hold 100 people,
who, judging
by every sci-fi movie,
would be brilliant scientists
and engineers
who are also super (bleep).
-(laughter)
-Musk says the journey
could take as little as 80 days,
unless there's traffic
on the 405.
Then they could just take
Sepulveda.
But they might as well leave
right now.
They'll arrive just in time to
see Trump set the earth on fire!
So, to pass the time on the way
to the red planet,
Musk has all kinds of fun
activities planned,
like movies, zero-G games,
figuring out how to build
a fuel refinement plant on Mars
so you don't die alone in space.
All the fun stuff the kids love.
But I'm sure they're still going
to have some hours to fill,
so comedians, how else will
these colonists
pass the time on their way
to Mars?
-Bruce Campbell!
-I won the game already.
HARDWICK: No, that's just
the first question.
It doesn't... I don't...
You still have to answer.
Oh, this is just other things
you can do?
Yeah.
-I'd come up with a cool quote
for when they land. -Yup.
'Cause right now, the best thing
they got is, uh,
"Suck our (bleep), Buzz Aldrin."
-HARDWICK: All right.
-(laughter)
So...
(applause and cheering)
It's a winner.
(applause and cheering swell)
(laughing):
Points.
Nick Swardson.
Floating turd volleyball.
-HARDWICK: Yeah, points.
-(laughter)
(applause and cheering)
Justin Willman. Yes.
Waiting for the beverage cart
to go by so you can finally pee.